people and the the imminent availability
of digital computers which started
really finally becoming commercially
available in the late 50s and by 1960
when plato was started were starting to
be all over the place which meant there
were like 20 of them instead of two but
you know the you know within every month
they were probably doubling the
university of illinois saw this as an
opportunity to get something get into a
major project that would be of great
educational import they viewed it as a
pure experiment at least they had that
skepticism I don't think they had this
the pure unadulterated vision that
Skinner had Skinner really had drunk the
kool-aid that his approach was the way
to go
the Plato people used the Skinner ideas
I think as a launchpad rather than as
you know we're going to literally
translate all of those ideas to the
computer so that is basically how things
started arriving the part 1 of the book
goes into much more detail about that
but basically all of this is driven by a
vision and if you look at any tech
project whether it's Apple Google
Facebook snapchat no matter what that's
out there today just like eBay or any
you know Microsoft Apple going all the
way back in time every one of these tech
companies has a vision and basically
every technology project starts with a
vision and it usually is something that
as a reaction to something that exists
already and the attitude is we can do it
better smarter cheaper faster or
something like that and some combination
or all of them and Plato was no
different even though was 1960 it was no
different and just like the jet airplane
was a reaction to propeller airplanes
which was probably reaction to you know
Wilbur and Orville Wright this pattern
just continues it's very predictable and
it's something I'm really fascinated by
for example you see that
I would argue that Facebook could never
have existed without MySpace and MySpace
probably would not have existed without
Friendster Google would have never
existed or you know had reason to exist
without being a reaction to say the
anatta
and inadequacies of Lycos or AltaVista
if any of those names ring a bell from
the 90s that's like 20 years ago that's
so weird
so the play-doh vision was to build this
incredibly flexible responsive system
because one of the rules of Skinner was
things have to be immediate the feedback
has to be immediate you don't want to
have a little child sitting there
finishing all their math problems and
then waiting for the rest of the class
that's a total verboten so with a
computer the the idea was well that's
that's actually easy it was it turned
out it wasn't easy but it became one of
the imperative underlying bullet-proof
mandates of the Plato philosophy I guess
the computer Plato philosophy of a
project to make sure the system was
insanely responsive and as we will see
there were some prizes surprises that
came with that that take up all of part
two of the book and further this vision
really was about we will build the
greatest most flexible computer platform
ever imagined that any teacher without
any training will be able to sit down
and compose whatever interactive lessons
tutorials simulations games you know
educational games whatever is
appropriate for their students they will
build and they will deploy to their
students and all will be good and this
drove the vision with the passion and
clarity I would argue of the Apollo
mission all during the 60s and I think
it's interesting that you know Kennedy
gave his famous speech in 61 right a few
months after the Plato's project started
and you know the optimism of that era
you know we can get someone to the
surely we can build a computer that can
you know basically teach any student in
the United States so you may hear the
phrase and if you open any newspaper or
magazine today or just browse around
social media you'll hear about news
about educational technology as a phrase
you hear schools talk about all the time
school board's debated all the time
should we spend more millions on it what
is it that kind of thing and the thing
you need to understand is during the
Plato era which is really the birth of
modern educational technology the the
idea was the the the definition the
thinking was that educational technology
means technology that educates and that
I think is very different than a lot of
what passes for educational technology
today which is more how do we spend
millions to teach students how to tweet
or use Facebook in an educational
setting or use Google and searches and
email and all of the capabilities of
Google or whatever company is offering
the service to a school district in
other words it's basically information
technology its IT for schools or in
universities and there isn't anywhere
near as much teaching through the system
but back in the 60s and the 70s and the
80s with the mission of Plato and
competitors to Plato them the idea was
we're going to teach with this system
and you know the teacher doesn't have to
do the teaching and it was a pretty
revolutionary and controversial idea so
let's move on to the untold story it's a
very trite expression there's a thousand
book titles that have that as their
subtitle and I was tempted not to
include it and just call the book the
friendly orange glow but then I figured
it would wind up in the novels section
here in the bookstore which might not
have been a bad idea but in this case
even though it's a trite expression
untold story I think it's about as
accurate and bewildering ly accurate
you can imagine because there are no
books no magazines articles no movies no
documentaries no 60 minute segments no
you know programs that you have ever
seen on Plato anywhere there's never
been a big wired cover story or even a
like back cover story or in the middle
cover story
according to Silicon Valley plato
basically doesn't exist and that's all
well and good and as it should be
so this has created a challenge for an
author who's writing a book about Plato
because usually when you try to do a
history of something you go to the
sources and as the first you know step
and you read what everybody else has
written and the problem is no one's ever
written anything on Plato so I had to go
around and interview everybody and it
took you know about 30 plus years and I
did seven million words of interview
transcripts that I typed myself that
took a few years but it was the only way
to get source material was to go talk to
the people and luckily they are still
around and that gets to an interesting
issue which we don't really have time to
talk about tonight but there is a
difference between history and
journalism when you're trying to dig up
a story and you know some people have
described me as a historian and I you
know I'm certainly not that I mean I
don't have that training I've read a lot
of history but I think with Plato's
story being so fresh and recent and the
majority people still around still alive
still answerable on email and phones
this was a task more you know in keeping
with the journalism profession or
practices at least if not profession and
so I approached this with a little bit
of both you know I had to go talk to
everybody try to figure out what the
story was that took a few years - one
thing to think about the Plato system
was developed at the University of
Illinois in urbana-champaign which is a
small town surrounded by many many miles
of corn literally I mean it's an island
of green it's go there in the summer and
you'll see what I'm talking about
five minutes in any direction and you're
surrounded by cornfields ten feet high
and what I have always been blown away
by with play-doh is the fact that even
at the University of Illinois I think
it's arguable that there's another
computer that's more famous than Plato
and that's the Hal 9000 from the movie
2001 and that's fictional it was you
know quote-unquote invented in Urbana
Illinois in the nineteen nineties if
you've watched the movie or read the
book and there are events where they
celebrate the birth of how in Urbana and
I went you know to one of them and I'm
going around going yep but but but what
about Plato you know and they're like
what who the Greek guy no he's like down
the hall and you know philosophy so this
is the kind of thing we've been up
against in trying to document the
history of Plato and let me just read a
couple of little things from the preface
I'm going to skip around to keep things
moving but that talk and try to address
this untold story thing because it
really is a huge factor in this book
it's kind of like this book was an
effort to solve a mystery and the
mystery was what the heck is Plato and
why do the people who experienced it
have this still this wide-eyed vision
like you know we saw the future before
any of you guys kind of thing and the
future being what everyone is doing now
which is this all day long so we were we
were all staring at the screen 40 years
ago imagine discovering that a small
group of people had to had invented a
fully functioning jet airplane capable
of flying long distances at hundreds of
miles per hour decades before the Wright
brothers cast their fragile craft into
the wind for 12 seconds over North
Carolina sand dunes in 1903 imagine how
such a discovery would disrupt our
common understanding of history the
story of Plato a computer system so far
ahead of its time at perhaps the least
known major 20th century technology
project may strike you as just as
impossible at 20 a story as as the 19th
century jet but Plato really happened it
is a story of inventors Mavericks
hackers geniuses visionary scientists
and educators who came together not so
long ago in the very heart of the
American Midwest a story that so
disrupts a conventional view of 20th
century technology history that it may
make you wonder as it has made this
author wonder how could this have
happened where are the books the
magazine articles the documentaries the
museum displays that should have covered
this story why has this story gone
untold why are we only finding out about
it now we celebrate the rise of the
ARPANET the Internet the World Wide Web
we celebrate the accomplishments of
Xerox Palo Alto Research Center which in
turn inspired Apple's Lisa and Macintosh
computers wood and much of the personal
computing environments we still use
today we celebrate the innovations
produced by legions of startup companies
and placed into the hands of millions
now billions of people innovations that
have changed the world
innovations people cannot imagine living
without we are living the very shocking
future that Alvin Toffler wrote about
warned us about 45 years ago in the
history of how we reach this future has
been researched deciphered studied
analyzed organized and disseminated far
and wide for long enough that the
stories become legend set in stone nerds
geeks and hackers are no longer outcasts
and ridiculed they're sought after
thought leaders many counted among the
tens of thousands of recent millionaires
and hundreds of billionaires the lists
of heroes names in the computer
revolution quote unquote
is long but there is an equally long
list of unknown computer pioneers the
people whose stories fill the pages of
this book
the level to which play-doh its people
and its history have been ignored is
extraordinary given not only how seminal
the innovations were and how early its
online community flourished
but how recently it happened plato was a
computer system but more important it
was a culture physical and online a
community that formed on its own with
its own jargon customs and idioms its
own caste thousands a world familiar to
us yet subtly foreign an entire era that
clashes with the accepted canonical
history of computing social media online
communities online games and online
education it's as if an advanced
civilization that once thrived on Earth
dwelled among us built a wondrous
technology and then disappeared as
quietly as they had arrived leaving
behind scraps of legend and artifacts
only a few noticed this bulk book is the
result of an effort to capture the
history of this lost culture of
innovation before it vanishes completely
by someone who had the great fortune to
come of age to become digital quote
unquote as it were within the very
within that very culture and thereby
having a chance to get to know some of
the people there their stories their
visions and their amazing technologies
technologies that we all now recognize
and use this book is also as much as as
much a biography of a vision as it is a
story behind the people of Plato every
technology story whether it's about the
steam engine textile loom light bulb
telephone airplane Model T or more
recently Macintosh Google search engine
or Tesla electric car has at its core a
vision and so
moving on to part three the friendly
orange glow and trying to explain what
that's all about it's not my term I
didn't make it up it's it's it is very I
love the term but it wasn't me it was
something I heard all the time from
Plato people and when I interviewed
people all the time
they would I guess the term is wax
rhapsodic about the friendly orange glow
and I will say that the very very first
time I saw Plato at the University of
Delaware in 1979 I was in the Music
Building and I'm walking wandering
through the campus is the first week I
was just a brand-new freshman I didn't
know anything and I see this darkened
classroom in the Music Building except
there's all this orange reflection on
people's faces and they have headphones
on and they're looking at very high
resolution screens that are all orange
graphics and it's all musical notation
on top just as beautiful as on a sheet
music and then the bottom half of the
screen is a keyboard and people are
reaching out and playing notes just as
if it's on the piano and they're clearly
hearing them in their headphones well
that wasn't what you usually heard about
what computers were usually you know
it's a stack of cards and you stuff them
into some reader and it you know some
priest somewhere comes out and shoes you
away and they take the cards and run it
through a job and maybe a few days later
you get your output which is all errors
and you have to start over again
so here was this interactive graphical
orange computer and I was hooked so that
was the first time I saw it I had no
idea what it was the story behind why
plato's display is orange it's really
remarkable and consumes a lot of the
project for that's described in part one
of the book in some ways it's a sad
story because I think it simply took too
long to get out to production and if
you've ever heard of this thing called
Moore's Law which you know Silicon
Valley has
made trillions of dollars by which
basically says that you know the cost of
chips computer chips is dramatically
falling every year and the and the speed
of the processing is de matically
doubling every year and that has
basically stayed straight all the way
till 2017 since like 1965 it's just
unbelievable so in the meantime the
play-doh project needed to come up with
a display for many many students to use
at the terminals that they were going to
interact with this teacher system
remember that's what this was all about
education the problem was that computer
memory in 1960-61 62 was insanely
expensive and to give you an idea just
how expensive it was basically $2 per
bit now
there's 8 bits in a byte and most of you
have probably a smartphone with you and
that probably has 16 gigabytes or 32 you
know whatever an Android or Apple or
whatever or 64 maybe so you're talking
about a device that in 1962 would have
cost something like five hundred million
dollars each and you would need computer
memory to run every display terminal
that was going to be on this system well
that would have cost about five hundred
thousand dollars for just a minimal
amount of memory per terminal per
student and you can imagine in schools
where the teachers can't even afford
chalk for the chalkboard
where are they going to call about
$500,000 per terminal for each student
you know that the numbers just didn't
add up so you know engineers being
engineers they saw this as an
opportunity rather than a problem that
they you know they could go invent
something and what they came up with was
really a fundamental patent from the
1960s that ironically the press
immediately saw what the future was and
the play-doh people didn't basically
they invented a flat
panel display that was you know quarter
of an inch thick filled with neon gas
and it was the plasma display that would
later become plasma televisions the same
invention they you know there may be one
hanging on the wall in here I don't know
but you know many homes have them and as
early as the mid 60's the media would
come down to Illinois and interview the
scientists and look at the single pixel
that they were experimenting on at that
point it's one dot trying to perfect
that and they would go AHA you're
building a flat-screen TV this is the
future you know the future is flat
television it's like wow we get it and
of course the play-doh people no no no
it's education education education and
the TV and you know the media people
like no no it's television it's
television so you know that's what it
takes to have a really focused mission
you know critical vision and they stuck
with it they were building this for
education and not for entertainment and
as we'll see so much for that idea that
didn't last long by the time the of the
early 70s very early 70s they had a 256
by 256 very primitive 4 inch by 4 inch
screen prototype and so they packed that
up in a incredibly rube goldberg box
that the engineers nicknamed the possum
trap and they carted that off to
Washington DC to present to the National
Science Foundation to get big big
funding to roll this out commercially or
well not commercially but you know in a
major multi-million dollar experiment at
the University of Illinois and an
surrounding geography area all the way
up to Chicago and let me read to the
scene from that demo because it's a
classic technology demo now when I it
starts by saying Cyril C er L is the
name of the lab the computer-based
education research lab Cyril engineering
technicians Jim Cano key
and Ray Ogden had been tasked with
taking one of the four inch prototype
plasma panels and incorporated
incorporating it into a full-sized
plywood mock-up of the Plato 4 terminal
for the demo the result was a big blue
plywood box with a tiny square screen in
front and center with a lid on the top
of the box you could open but you had to
be careful fitting fiddling about inside
we call it the possum traps as Cano key
inside the lid was a crude but
functional microfiche slide mechanism
but it was possible to get your hands
caught in it if you weren't careful and
maybe even hands cut off the technicians
carefully set up the big blue clunky
possum trap terminal on a table set up
all the cables and got the live
telephone connection back to Cyril up
and running which is remarkable this is
about 71 and they're doing a live
long-distance telephone connection all
the way back to the Cyril computer which
is I guess about 1,200 miles away this
was not normal in 1970-71 it was
perfectly normal in the world of Plato
though they did demos all over the world
everything worked fine during the test
and then just as we were about to me
make the presentation just before we had
difficulty with the phone line says Cano
key then the plasma display didn't light
moments before the demo was about to
start the electronics inside the
terminal were so extremely delicate that
Cano key had doubts about the possum
trap would survive the trip out to
Washington but had made it and Cano key
and the other technicians had taken
great care to gently set up everything
and now it was not working seconds
before Bitzer Donal Bitzer is the
founder of Plato was he's he's the
showman and he did all of the the demos
was about to start Bitzer assess the
situation and then did what any leader
of a technology project does when he is
about to go on with a demonstration that
will determine whether his project gets
funding from the United States
government or not he took his hand and
slammed the side of the possum trap hard
my heart went into my throat says Cano
key when he slammed the side of the box
which again was so sensitive but by some
miracle the hole
thing lit up with text on the screen and
the phone line came through and we were
ready for the demonstration and that was
that was pretty much the way things went
with play-doh demos just one quick
comment they they really did build these
big bulky terminals that were the size
of small washing machines and they
really did have microfiche slide
projectors in them you have to
understand that a flat a flat panel
gasps plasma display is a sheet of glass
basically and it's only a quarter of an
inch thick and it's transparent so there
were mirrors behind it in the terminal
and at the top there was a slide
projector and you could project Bing
Bing Bing Bing and out color photos from
taken from slides and and put onto a
microfiche plastic you know sheet and
then you superimpose text and graphics
on top of that so it was it was the best
of both worlds in terms of a fairly rich
multimedia environment for the early 70s
there wasn't video we didn't have that
yet but this was pretty darn impressive
and to add to the Rube Goldberg Ness of
this kind of setup the slide mechanism
ran on compressed air which meant that
there were you would have to cart around
a huge tube of compressed air to the
demos and of course airlines eventually
caught on that this is not a good thing
to do not a good thing to transport you
know what exactly is in that tube sir
and so eventually they had to resort to
bringing some kid along who would sit on
top of a basketball and provide the
necessary pressure so the
let's let's move on to the dawn of cyber
culture and the first thing to think
about is really culture the sural
laboratory was a very very special place
and none of this would have ever
happened I would not be standing here
this book would have never been written
had not the culture of this laboratory
been so unusual and so special and
unusual in the sense that you know
computer labs in the 60s and 70s were
often you know locked up places that you
were not allowed in and you basically
better be wearing a lab coat and be a
postdoc if you're expecting to have
access even at places at MIT and
Stanford you know things like that
they're their labs are legendary too but
they were generally restricted and it
was hard to get into the lab at Searle
was notorious for being so open and the
management so loose that people joked
that there really was no management and
there was no no restrictions on who
could just wander into the building and
that led to some very interesting things
and there was a philosophy behind it
that I discovered which is remarkable
then and totally applicable now I think
the the folks who ran the lab from
Bitzer on down welcomes anyone from any
gender any age if you were a kid and you
showed promise and interest and
determination in other words you were a
pest and you never you kept coming back
they put you to work they basically said
okay if you're not going to go away try
this go solve this problem and if you
can solve that we'll give you another
problem and they just would repeat
repeat repeat and eventually they might
say you're solving a lot of problems do
you want to get paid and a lot of kids
would go like I can get paid to have fun
you know Wow
who needs a degree but that was another
problem and so what you found all during
the 60s and then in a tidal wave in the
early 70s was word got out all over
Champaign Urbana that Searle was the
cool place to be it had these cool
orange computers and it was the home of
the orange glow basically and people
would wander in from all over town but
particularly across the street where
there was a laboratory school run by the
University called uni high and those
kids had it lucky because they were
literally a stone's throw from the door
of Cyril and they wandered in all the
time
and I document the stories of a number
of those kids because they became
incredibly instrumental in building a
lot of the most famous features of Plato
and part 2 of this book dives deep into
this whole era of how I guess you could
call it the youth culture took over
Plato and what's ironic about it is you
know Plato again was this thing about
education we're going to build a teacher
out of a machine and that's what's going
to teach students and now we're
discovering that the students are like
you know your teaching machine is very
cool but you know there's a lot more you
could do with this thing and they
ironically started teaching the adults
what you could do and for most of part
two of the book I just go through a
remarkable series of innovations that
they brought to the system on their own
these were mostly like you know
teenagers that were some of them were
not even in college yet and in a amazing
period 12-month period between 73 and 74
you suddenly saw chat rooms instant
messaging message forums email massive
multiplayer games basically the original
DNA for almost everything you see now
was formulated then in fact a lot of the
original design elements that that
people you know right phd's about in
present-day video games we're all
present on Plato in the early 70s and
what's also remarkable I was talking
before about the fact that a lot of
times technology is created in response
to the inadequacies of previous
technologies and in this case there
weren't a lot of predecessors to the
kinds of social computing capabilities
that
these kids brought they just wanted to
yak they just wanted to hang out online
with their friends and you know it
wasn't like there was a previous system
that did this and they had all seen it
and used it this was literally novel
there were no books magazines or
anything there were no you know
president's predecessors at all one
person told me a great quote which I'm
retrying to draw from memory so I may
not get an exact it's in the book
where basically you know they thought
they had built built the world's
greatest educational teaching machine
but what in fact they had built was the
world's greatest pinball machine ever
built and it is really ironic how over
the course of the 70s and into the 80s
so many students both in high school and
in college would be exposed to play-doh
which by then had many thousands and
thousands of hours of lessons available
on subjects from you know anthropology
to zoology and everything in between the
sciences the humanities literature
French Latin all Russian Hebrew all
kinds of amazing tutorials and
simulations that were still remarkable
to this day and you know ironically for
many kids not the majority but for many
of them the most interesting topic on
Plato was Plato and they wanted to know
how they could Bend and shape it and
transform it and ironically again and
oftentimes what that led to was them
either dropping out of school or being
forced to leave school because their
grades plummeted to zero and even that
turned out to not be such a bad thing
which in a way as a precursor to what
would happen many years later with
Silicon Valley you know coming in and
just plucking kids out of you know
computer science classes in freshman
year at Stanford or MIT and joining
Google or whatever and kids got the
message real quick that you know why do
I need a full-time
full degree if I can be making six
figures by by age 20 and I mean there
was also the story of Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates and Mark Zuckerberg and all
the rest who dropped out of school and
went off to become billionaires so there
was a pattern and a lure interestingly
with the play-doh era there wasn't the
draw of money there wasn't the the spell
of riches that could pour on you the way
so many people sort of take the internet
today it's almost like a gold rush
that's perpetual we didn't have that I
didn't see that you know when I was
exposed to Plato and you know so the
commercial sort of mercantile side of
the social computing revolution had not
happened yet
and speaking of you know revolution I
used this book to put to put a you know
somewhat of a historians hat on I sort
of have a challenge for real historians
which is find prior examples where
something like Plato existed and we're
you know I would cite the evidence the
copious evidence that I've accumulated
in this book as evidence that the social
interpersonal computer revolution was
thriving not only started but was
thriving before the personal computer
revolution ever got started and that is
basically historical heresy so you heard
it here first tonight but I argue that
it's just look at the talk to the people
go look at the evidence what you had on
Plato in the early 70s but you know the
era when the founders of Google were in
diapers and Apple and Microsoft hadn't
had several years to go before they'd
even be incorporated and those those
kids were still teenagers what you had
was a thriving mature online world
people completely addicted to the system
and ironically
the Plato system moved in phases played
at 1 2 3 & 4 with Roman numerals Plato 1
started in 1962 started in 61 Plato 3
was in about 63 and lasted till about 71
and then Plato 4 was the big deal that's
the thing that the nsf-funded and the
irony is there that for many students it
wasn't Plato Roman numeral four was
Plato IV as an intravenous and because
it really was just like people would get
addicted and spend way too much of their
lives on line today and let me just read
a little passage that I think will help
describe this phenomenon before I do I
just wanted to mention one experience I
remember vividly from being at the
University of Delaware in freshman year
I had some friends come up to visit they
were you know from high school and there
were the first time at Delaware and of
course I had to you got to see the Plato
system you know it's the future it's
orange and they're like yeah whatever so
I dragged him into a play-doh classroom
and I'm showing them this thing and for
years I've been trying to describe what
it was what it felt like to me to try to
explain with enthusiasm to my friends
and I finally figured it out and it's
probably something that everyone here
can relate to and that is have you ever
tried to get your pet to watch
television in other words you know get
your dog to sit in front of the screen
and you know they will they'll look at
the screen for a minute with that blank
expression and if it were a cartoon
character you know the eyes would have
the swirls you know like they're like
that and then it's squirrel
you know they they're not seeing it they
don't they don't get it and I kind of
had the impression that that was the way
it was out here I was like here is the
future this is what we're all going to
be doing in 10 20 years and it's already
here you know chat rooms I mean you can
instant message people you can like do
screen sharing you don't even know what
that is but it's cool you know and it
was kind of like when are we going for
beers you know
so and one way I described this in in
the book is as follows only a few
minutes exposure to Plato four was
enough for people to realize that it up
ended that generally received view of
computers up to that point if one were
to accept how books movies and media had
betrayed them
Plato was an evil self-aware
intelligence first seemingly benign but
after something going horribly wrong now
bent on destroying humanity it almost
certainly wasn't 2001's how looking back
it threw you through a foreboding round
red glass eye nor was Plato some boring
number crunching tape machine card
reader dead data processing behemoth
found in big banks and government
agencies plato was your friends looking
back at you through friendly orange dots
and I also described it which I'll just
paraphrase in the interest of time but
imagine in the 70s if you're having
dinner with the family and you happen to
casually mention oh today I chatted with
people in Hawaii New York Illinois and
Delaware and they look at you with great
horror because of the phone bill cost
and then you explain no no no this was
through term talk on Plato and they're
like term what and then you have to
spend the next hour of dinner
painstakingly explaining what it means
to chat with someone online and why that
is actually an interesting thing to do
and why it's fun and and it's besides
the fact that it's free and the you know
by the time dinner's over most of the
dinner your family members would have
run for the hills and and not even been
around the table now contrast that with
today if the family is even sitting
around the same table at dinner they're
probably all sitting there with one fork
in one hand and a smartphone or a tablet
in the other everyone individually
immersed in their own private online
world chatting or talking with their
friends and reading news feeds
and oblivious to the issues concerns or
discussions that are going on from
anyone else around the table
and what they're doing is essentially
the equivalent of everything people were
doing socially online on Plato in the
70s and you know today they wouldn't
they wouldn't bat an eye if you said I
just chatted with somebody in Hawaii or
something like that back then
it was a major dissertation to try to
explain it but so one other way I
describe this is that what what these
teenagers really did was create what
Silicon Valley pundits would much later
called the killer app which you know has
always been defined or at least the
simplest way I've always defined it as
its people in other words the most
powerful compelling application to use
all this fancy technology is just to
connect people together and all the rest
is just noise but what people really use
computers for nowadays is getting you
know finding out where people are going
what they're doing what they're thinking
what their opinions are and that sort of
thing good bad or ugly one thing we've
all learned is that this technology has
scaled so has scaled the good the bad
and the ugly which is you know something
we can talk about so I don't really have
time to run into this and with part
three but basically what part three is
about is this dream of getting all of
this educational technology to scale and
it's the same dream that every startup
has today you have an idea in the garage
or at the kitchen table with your laptop
or whatever you get a couple of
collaborators together you do a startup
company maybe get some funding maybe get
some traction there's a lot of maybes
but that's the way it works and maybe
you go viral and maybe you get to scale
and scale nowadays it's a few billion
people we're long past a few you know
thousand or a few even tens of millions
I was doing my startups having 20
million people was considered amazing
now that's considered you know to beacon
to be very concerned about but so I'll
just briefly mention that the the
University of Illinois did something
incredibly daring which had never been
done before and that was you know in the
series of firsts and pioneering efforts
they decided to license all of the
technology they had built to a
commercial company and the NSF was in
horror the university is like what and
the lab was like you know even they
couldn't quite understand it and yet
after two years of lawyers they pulled
it off and in 1976 Plato was essentially
sold commercially to a company called
control data which does not exist
anymore which is about where I'll leave
it that's that is the whole story of
control data and the reasons why it
didn't work or become viable are a
Harvard Business School case study times
a hundred and if for no other reason
you know I urge anyone with any you know
daring of manoa magining going into a
start-up or doing some kind of
entrepreneurial effort to think about
learn the lessons from control data
because they are the classic lessons
that are repeated you know over and over
again so with that why don't we open it
up to questions so thank you very much
for its reading this is a great talk
right and thank you um so just maybe a
few guesses why why was it unknown and
why is it still unknown what but what
what is a curse of these well I think
one thing you know I I liken it to a
start-up I try to do a few years ago in
the movie-going space which I learned is
defined as the M word to Silicon Valley
if you even dare so mention
movies to Silicon Valley they completely
freak leave the conference room lock the
door call the cops and you know check to
see if you're gone yet it's it's not a
popular project to dive into even though
you think it might be fun in the
play-doh world it was the e word for
education and basically I think it's
safe to say that education in the United
States has never been like a first-class
buzz word its second or third class and
as the microcomputer revolution roared
on in the 70s and 80s and exploded and
people started making money and Wall
Street woke up and realized this is the
future gold rush and it's still going on
now and money-making became really the
thing and the technology pace of
Technology accelerated so fast it's
still dizzying the internet rose up the
web rose up personal computers with far
more powerful capabilities than anything
Plato ever had rose up and Plato was
still mission oriented to the e word
education even though it had all the
stuff it had all the ingredients they
could have owned the internet they could
have owned personal computing even and I
talked about that in detail in part 3
how control data the engineers built a
personal computer in 1975 that did
everything that the IBM PC did in 1981
they had a six year head start and CDC's
rule was if you can plug it into the
wall it's too small and they they
basically felt that it has to be a
mainframe it has to cost 10 million and
up and anything smaller than that is not
what we do here at control Data
Corporation and well they paid the price
as the microcomputer revolution wore on
so economics were one thing the fact
that it was education oriented even
though all the social stuff was there
even though it's now I think documented
that it was really the interpersonal
computer revolution starting before the
PC revolution it was mostly dogs staring
into televisions they just didn't quite
they didn't grok it they didn't
see what it was not enough not enough of
a critical mass appreciated what this
dizzying future was going to be if you
think about the 60s every depiction of
computers even in Star Trek you know and
ironically we're getting back to Star
Trek now with the with the Google home
and the Amazon device which you go you
know I won't use the phrase because
it'll probably trigger devices all over
the country when this airs but I'll say
it anyway you know Google home order 1
million copies of the friendly orange
glow watch the system crash
but you know now it just like in Star
Trek computer working you know calculate
the distance to this planet you know
that's 9 it's light-years whatever
there was no notion of social with any
depiction of computers even how the 9000
anything was all the same old thing you
talk to it that was considered
futuristic and unfortunately that's
where we're headed it's going to be
interesting what that does to social
which is you know will it become
something that fades away I doubt it
because I think the killer app is here
forever
but anyway yeah ok these last two
questions all right my first job was in
one of those companies selling time on
the gigantic mainframes that you were so
scornful the different world yes um this
makes me think of soul of any machine
new machine of course yeah and it's
great that this all comes forward
because it's been a world that's been
magic and mystery in so much in history
but I'm looking at what we've got now I
think about companies like leapfrog that
do educational technology in the sense
that you mean it that help people learn
and I wonder if any of the technology
from the from the play-doh world
actually came forward to what's used
today in learning applications and
devices yes like that um based on what I
looked around and saw and talked to
people I would say very little
is another sort of tragedy what I have
found in years of looking at this field
of education and training both K through
12 University and government and
industry is that it's just repeatedly
reinvented and it's a gigantic waste of
resources to keep reinventing things and
many of the things that were invented in
the 60s and 70s on Plato even the 60s
particularly very powerful capabilities
in the system to judge the types
response that a student might make
really you know you could type in
natural language you could type in very
scientific equations chemistry symbols
or whatever Plato and just gobble it up
and knew exactly what you were talking
about it was very flexible and fungible
it allowed you to make mistakes you know
it wasn't exact wording like Skinner
would have done they had learned that it
has to be you know very flexible and
patient with the student even with typos
and stuff a lot of that answered judging
capability still hasn't been replicated
and the other thing I'll say is that one
of the as I said before the great vision
of Plato was to get the system to the
point where it was so incredibly
flexible that anybody just a mere mortal
could sit down and create a magnificent
interactive lesson for their students
you didn't have to be a computer whiz or
rocket scientist you could just be a
math teacher or an English teacher or
something and that vision basically
failed and the promise of it was that
over time Moore's law would work on the
authoring of Education just the way it
had on chips you know every year the
cost would come down the cost of
production of an hour of interactive
student learning would come down and not
only did it not come down it's gone up
every year and so to produce a big
interactive course now is no different
than what it costs to produce a big
interactive video game the budgets of
which are very similar to the budgets of
Hollywood films we're talking a hundred
million dollars to develop a superhit
game that will sell a billion you know
copies or something like that so the
cost of production never fixed itself
yeah
hi I was one of those kids who spent
many years at Searle starting from the
age of 11 I mean not your I spent nights
you know I was there all the time 11 12
13 and the it was interesting hearing
you talk about the openness of the
culture so that's definitely what I
found
I also saw Jerry Glenn and Don Cohen
were mentioned in the book and they were
the ones who came to the school where
all the faculty brats went Leal and and
started recruiting us to teach us
computer programming and one of and I've
emailed you so what we had a bit of a
discussion one of the aspects of that
open culture was some molestation and
abuse of kids and you know what what you
said was that nobody that you didn't
tell the stories you knew about the
stories but you didn't tell them because
nobody would go on the record and so I'm
here I'm on camera and I'm not gonna
mention names because you also advised
me not to say anything because there's
rich people and I should get a lawyer
and I've had a really hard time figuring
out how to deal with this with you know
with the me2 movement and your book
coming out and and I have a 12 year old
son who's you know in a in a magnet
program who's you know one of those kids
who might end up with one of these
molesters so you know I just wonder like
what are the chances of bringing out
some of these stories and and just
letting parents know about individuals
and institutions where their kids are at
risk even today well I mean what I would
say is what I've said for years is that
you know ever since the movie spotlight
came out I used that as the example and
the guidebook for I think what is needed
to be done to get something like this in
a legitimate you know well researched
well
bulletproof way out to the public in a
way that perhaps could be prosecuted you
know if that's the course that's
appropriate you know I got to say I'm
not a lawyer and in my you know I didn't
seek out this stuff what I found is that
it was not happening with the staff of
the universe Earle lab these were
peripheral you know folks who happen to
be running some classes that kids were
in and yet no one in 20 years of people
coming to me more than twenty years of
people coming to me would anyone go on
the record every single person insisted
on silence and not mentioning this and
everything so you know I didn't see a
story there for me to pursue you know if
I put a journalist hat on there was just
nothing I could do with it and you know
if if there's something out there and
you know it sounds like there may be
then I don't you know there are probably
organizations that can help get this
kind of thing done and you know probably
the best ways to start is to look at the
organizations that were mentioned in
spotlight you know because they really
do exist and they're out there and that
might be the best way to get going I
mean there's not much I can do in my
book again it just it was not a story
that was documented no one would name
names or anything so you know or go on
the record and and so you know there's
there's nothing I can do with it and I
you know I talk to lawyers about it and
you know they basically agreed with me
that you know unless I can get you know
a real long series of depositions and
then it becomes a completely different
project to what I was doing which is
basically documenting the history of
Plato first and foremost you know what
you find when you study a very large
group of people in any walk of life is
there's probably some bad or operators
in that group of people it's just pure
human nature and they're going to do bad
things and you know it could completely
overwhelm a project to document the
product the core project that's going on
in this case Plato if I dwelled on that
but I couldn't dwell on it because I had
no nothing to go by
you know I wish you luck you've got at
least one person okay all right well
thanks very much for coming I really
appreciate it thank you and I guess I'll
be sticking around if anybody wants to
get a book signed thank you books are
behind the register and if you can
please fold up your chair thank you
you're watching book TV on c-span -
television for serious readers here's
our primetime lineup
first up Noam Cohen former New York
Times tech columnist details the growth
of Silicon Valley and the impact it has
on politics and public policy then at
8:45 Rachel Botsman discusses the impact
technology has had on trust
then on book TVs afterwards at 10:00
p.m. astronaut scott kelly recalls his
record-setting time in space he's
interviewed by former NASA Administrator
Charles Bolden and we wrap up our
primetime programming at 11:00
Edward Ayers provides a history of the
civil war that all happens tonight on
c-span choose book TV 72 hours of
nonfiction authors and books this
holiday weekend television for serious
readers and now here's Noam Cohen on the
growth and influence of Silicon Valley
hello we're gonna get started here
tonight
my name is Seth manikin I'm the director
of the communications forum and a couple
of quick announcements before we start
first communication forums are held
three times a semester six times a year
if you would like to be informed of
future events there is a sign-up sheet
over there put your name and email and
we will promise that we will only send
you news about our six events a year we
have pretty good ones we had Sarah
Vowell earlier this year John Hodgman
last semester these three we have some
great stuff planned for next semester
already also tonight's forum is being
filmed by c-span so during the question
part of the of the forum if you would go
up to one of the microphones and also
hopefully state your name and your
question
another reason we asked you to state
your name is because we then do a
write-up of all of the forums afterwards
which you will be able to read a couple
of days after the event on our website
which is calm forum mit.edu
and the last announcement is that this
event tonight is co-sponsored by radius
which is another group here at MIT I am
thrilled to be able to introduce these
three it is a different three than we
initially thought would be here because
Jeff how is he called me up at a little
past five because his daughter was
puking and as the father of two young
kids myself I said please stay home and
so fortunately Chris couch who writes a
lot about technology works with the Kahn
forum is a brilliant journalist in her
own right has agreed to fill in as a
moderator but let me do introduce
everyone
Noam Cohen is the author of the new book
that know-it-alls and that will also be
a hashtag tonight and I think moving
forward the res know-it-alls gotta get
on that yep
no when I worked together a decade and a
half ago I've known him ever since he is
a great guy and a brilliant journalist
he covered the influence of the internet
on the larger culture for the New York
Times where he wrote the link by link
column beginning in 2007 his first book
that know-it-all is the rise of Silicon
Valley is a political powerhouse and
social wrecking ball is an intellectual
history of Silicon Valley and critically
examines how its disruptive culture and
ideology belittles civility empathy and
even democracy it was published in
October 2017 and it is available for
purchase right here and in addition to
to supporting open discussion we also
support both bookstores and authors so
please by all means buy the book it's a
great book Chris and I have both read it
and loved it - nomes
left is Sarah Anne Watson Sarah is a
technology critic who writes and speaks
about emerging issues in the
intersection of Technology culture and
society her work has appeared in the
Atlantic